good evening my name is Anne Thornton
and I am vice provost and university
librarian at Columbia University and I'm
delighted to provide the welcome for
this evening's program in 2008 the
Alexander Foundation generously donated
four million dollars to columbia
university libraries to hire a jewish
studies librarian and to support
collections in jewish studies since that
time we were able to catalogue and make
available nearly all of our 1600 Hebrew
manuscripts hire a full-time librarian
focusing on Jewish Studies and ensure
that columbia university libraries is
internationally known for its Jewish
Studies collections the annual normani
alexander lecture celebrates the
alexander foundations great gift to us
and demonstrates our commitment to
supporting the field of jewish studies
at Columbia and around the world and I'd
like to acknowledge gelb endermen of the
Norman Alexander foundation who is the
daughter of Norman Alexander who is here
this evening thank you so much Gail for
being here for your support Michelle
says nur the normani alexander librarian
for jewish studies will introduce
tonight's speaker Michelle thank you and
I'll add to our thanks for the lovely
normani alexander library bags that
you'll see over on the right side and
feel free to take take them with you and
David Reutimann is the joseph meyerhoff
professor of modern Jewish history at
the University of Pennsylvania he was
also the l a-- deriv off director of the
herbert decat center for advanced Judaic
Studies at the University of
Pennsylvania from 1994 to 2014 he's the
author of many books and articles most
recently a best-selling books his
best-selling Hebrew book of the modern
era the book of the Covenant of confess
Horowitz and it's remarkable legacy in
2004 professor Raeder man has served on
the board and as vice president of the
Association Association of Jewish
Studies and on the boards of
Conference of American rabbis the
Journal of reform judaism and the rena
the renaissance society of america and
the world union of jewish studies and
his influence on the world of jewish
studies and beyond is well known last
year 31 of his colleagues and former
students presented him with jewish
culture in early modern Europe essays in
honor of David B ruderman as a testament
to his great work and achievements
without further ado I'm pleased to
present to you professor David ruderman
will speak at tonight's normani
Alexander lecture on Jewish Studies on
missionaries masoom Adam and masculine
an entangled history of Christians Jews
and those in between in 19th century
Europe as a reader I do want to thank
the Columbia library and Michelle in
particular for this wonderful invitation
it is an honor to be the Norman
Alexander lecturer and Jewish Studies
and I thank Yale for her enormous
stewardship of this wonderful gift to
Columbia and to the Jewish people I it
is is really great to be back at
Columbia I actually have a masters from
gershon cone who at that time was the
professor of Jewish history and I recall
I'm I just walked around before it's
amazing this place hasn't changed in 50
years at least not on the surface and I
just felt the ghosts of all my teachers
were all around here and it looks like
the the architecture that they've read
that hasn't been much refurbishing in
the last 50 years either I didn't notice
it in that maybe I wasn't looking very
carefully in any case it did bring back
memories in the course of after I began
my studies here at Columbia gerson cone
announced that he was no longer going to
study Jewish history he was going to
make Jewish history by becoming
Chancellor of the geological seminary
across the street and he had a very
distinguished career and had a great
impact upon my life but that's all in
the past and now I am here
back at columbia ms it's a wonderful
opportunity I'm speaking about a new
subject for me those of you who know my
work know that I'm an early modernist so
therefore jumping into the 19th century
and even moving as far as Eastern Europe
from Western Europe is is quite a
stretch but you know when you get to be
an old age you know and an old guy you
know an alter kocker as we say what the
hell I mean it doesn't matter you know
just you're having a good time do your
thing so I you know as I'd like many
other things this subject came to me as
a result of reading a footnote I runs
what wrote a book on a convert after I
read at least she have a Carl box book
on converts and I i found a footnote of
a convert she hadn't done enough on and
i wrote a whole book on him after that
but she stimulated me as i told her and
similarly the last book that Michelle
mentioned a book about a Hebrew
bestseller from the 18th century in
tracing its steps into the nineteenth
and twentieth century i discovered this
handsome man over here he's not a jew
Alexander McCall and his beautiful wife
i'm going to show you his whole family
in a second and all of a sudden there
was a big affair going on here there's
something really happening in the 19th
century that that's so somehow intrigued
me so i began to investigate and this
has become a subject of the last year a
little more so this is clearly a work in
progress I'm not there yet but I'm about
to launch a larger project and at least
what I want to try to do is show you in
the course of the next 40 minutes or so
why this subject is so intriguing and
what and why it might interest a number
of people here I'm trying to think of
anything else i should say before i
begin so why don't i just launched in
and michelle is kindly going to show you
a few slides i'm not going to rely that
i'm not a powerpoint person but I
there's so many great pictures when you
go into the 19th century as opposed to
the early modern period all of a sudden
the documentation and the pictures
I just hit you in the face so you can
ignore I just want to show you had a lot
of family he was he took very seriously
the commandment of be fruitful and
multiply and they all look kind of you
know English I don't know how else to
describe them recall Elizabeth and
Nicole Finn she is very important i'll
talk about her in a second so that's
enough for now let me begin with an
overall introduction we live in a time
of scholarship when most of the taboos
about the study of the jewish past have
been removed this is especially dramatic
with respect to the study of jewish
converts defined disparagingly as masuma
deem in jewish tradition and even in
traditional jewish scholarship those
apostates who have left the Jewish faith
often treated outside the pale of Jewish
civilization or as oddities who became
famous or notorious by overcoming their
Jewish particularities aura self-hating
Jews who end up as adversaries of their
former co-religionists but this is all
changed in recent years particularly the
scholarship of Todd Edelman only last
year his large book on on Jewish
converts has come out I should mention a
former student of mine le schenker who
also has a forthcoming book from from
Stanford about about Russian Jewish
converts of course le chef carlebach we
mentioned Yaakov deutsch and a whole
group of others who have really created
a whole field of the study of the
convert on the other hand the figure of
the missionary is a subject relatively
untouched by historians of Jewish
cultural and social history however it
is studied in great intensity by
historians of the church missions and
this is in itself a vast historical
enterprise missionaries as cultural
brokers in post-colonial literature and
studies of European imperialism and sub
I'll turn people's have is also a very
important subject of studying the
nineteenth and twentieth century but
this is hardly a broad subject for
Jewish historians
of course in the 19th century the
primary group of missionaries were the
London missionaries called the London
society for the gumming up the title
right for the persuasion of Jews for no
no no no I'll get it in a second I was
going to say for the conversion of the
Jews but it's not that that's not the
exact title they were active in London
throughout the 1920s century and they
had a vast empire of of come of
missionaries all over Europe and clearly
they are the background and we have some
work on this London society mel scott
many years ago wrote a small book on the
subject raphael Mahler the Israeli
historian and more recently yessiree
Albert Hall has a very interesting
article about these London missionaries
and Habad don't ask me how they're
connected but they are or they were they
were certainly they tolerated each other
and there is a young Polish woman who
I've learned a great deal from name in
fact pronounce her name correctly
Agnieska jagodzinski who is now writing
an entire book and is actually finished
in polish on the London society in
Poland dealing obviously with Polish
Jewry and you'll hear more about that in
a second I want to focus on one
individual and you've seen his picture
already and these of course his family
alexander mccall i choose him not only
because he was a key intellectual and
political leader of the society but one
of its most profound intellectuals
deeply learn it in Jewish literature and
intimately familiar with contemporary
Jews and Judaism as you will see
educated in the West living in the East
he spent ten years in Warsaw conversant
in Hebrew and Yiddish and deeply
committed to Jewish learning while
acutely critical of the Talmud and
Jewish law and the rabbi's macaw
represents a remarkable case study of a
dialectical relationship of love and
hate intense devotion to his subjects
while derogating the very core of their
beliefs he demonstrate
profoundly the rich complexity of his
mindset entanglements with Jews and
Judaism so I'm going to so here I i
guess the title of my talk is a little
bit false advertising I'm going to
really speak about one missionary and
not missionaries although London society
there a lot but I think he's both
typical and as you will see very
atypical at the same time I'm going to
mention two of his accolades to miss you
madam so you get to so that's plural
right one of them will come up
especially because of what he does with
relation McCall and the muskie leme are
going to come in at the ends in other
words most of my project now has been
focused on the missionary himself but I
want to show you the long-term where
this project is going and the muskie
leme who respond to mccall are making it
such an interesting story in other words
it's not it is really a very broad
conversation going on within the context
of European Jewish history of the 19th
century it is also transnational because
we're speaking about a guy who's born in
in in london in were actually practices
in london is born in ireland but clearly
spends his time in eastern europe and
goes back and forth and therefore we are
speaking about a cause celebra perhaps
not as great as the Damascus blood libel
of 1840 and in terms of its enormous
ramifications throughout Europe which of
course Jonathan Frankel has documented
so brilliantly but it is a minor khoa
celebra because it involves both
Christians and Jews throughout all of
Europe as you will see and therefore it
became a conversation or a revival of
the Jewish Christian debate in the 19th
century in a very different form in a
very exciting way that's was so how
compelling I couldn't put it down as you
will see so I'm going to speak mostly
about McCall but I'm going to after
giving you a sense of him I'm going to
move on to talk about a little bit about
is about his mission Madame his his
converts the few that he did succeed in
converting and then I want to talk about
the muscular croissants and and show you
what the whole
sure might look like when i eventually
get done writing this book but at this
stage of course i'm still a long way to
go let me introduce my subject of McCall
with three snapshots each offering a
distinct and different aspect of this
man lund society for promoting
Christianity amongst the Jews that's the
exact title okay I slipped it but that's
what we're talking about in a eulogy
written by Reverend William Ayers one of
McCall's close disciples who dedicated
one of his own works to his teacher this
were written in 1863 he points out the
uniqueness and McCall in contrast to
other Christians who had previously
devoted their lives to the study of
Judaism McCall was different from John
Lightfoot the great scholar of the
biblical text who studied the rabbi's
merely to comprehend the Bible more
deeply says Ayers he was also different
from wagons aisle and aizen monger whose
fiery darts boo geofeed a Democrat adju
xand Judaism instead he approached the
Jews he met and their literature which
he consumed with a new spirit of love
and goodwill here I'm paraphrasing a
erst in this sense he was unique and
opened up new channels of communication
between Christians and Jews so
interestingly this Christian paints
McCall within the context of the history
of Christian apologetics towards Jews
and he distinguishes between on the one
hand the biblical exigent and on the
other hand those who came out strongly
with all of their storm against Judaism
in Jewish texts here is a Christian who
approaches Jews with love and devotion
all right and we will explore that
equation in a second my second a
introductory snapshot is totally
different and here I get a chance to
introduce one of my mission Madine very
interesting figure Stanislaw hoga hota
and I don't have a picture of him so I'm
not going to i'm not going to point any
pictures yet Stanislaw hoga is well
known Sid Lyman many years ago in one of
his many articles wrote on this man and
tried to reconstruct the story which he
then showed was not true and he was
absolutely right but the story is even
more elaborate than Sid Lyman described
sanus la hoja was as you will see the
translator of McCall's famous work which
i will introduce very very soon called
the old paths or nitty vote olam in
Hebrew he translated into Hebrew which
was this very strong polemic against the
Talmud so hoga became was an Eastern
European Jew who became a convert and
worked with a mekole very very intensely
for many years but when he came to
England after this book it appeared in
the middle of the of the 19th century
hoga begins to write books against his
former teacher in a work which he called
sere naman or the faithful missionary
work written long after he had converted
to Protestantism and allegedly worked on
the notorious translation of McCall's
magnum opus as i mentioned he clearly
had distance himself and his association
from the London society in general and
mccall in particular this complex
apostate apparently had second thoughts
he did not wish to return to the Jewish
fold as some had suggested nor did he
want to make peace with the community
had long deserted but he believed that
Jews like him could find a space within
the Christian faith by simultaneously
holding on to their customs and
practices rabbinical aha did not deserve
the rebuke mccall had given it that's
unbelievable he would write that after
translating a text which is 500 pages of
rebuke of the town would in the rabbi's
he attacked the in company
insincere missionaries the London
society and made light of McCall's
claimed that he had directly created
Reform Judaism which is another
interesting thing that we will hopefully
we'll come back to reform judaism in in
england at least he also implied that
McCoy was hardly the sole author of
nativo dolim in the first place so even
more ironic that he should be writing
this anti Talmudic text and now
repudiating it entirely while
maintaining his belief in Jesus he would
not repudiate the rabbinic understanding
of Judaism so we have here a fascinating
reversal and transformation as well just
think here and I've actually traced hoga
steps he wrote several other books and
believe it or not he was published
throughout the 1850s in the Jewish
Chronicle so even though they knew he
was an apostate they were he was still a
very learning Jew and they published him
there and he talks about all kinds of
interesting things mostly biblical
interpretations but clearly it was a
very open world but as you see already
my my interest those of you that know
some of my previous work mingle
identities or braided identities is
something that I find absolutely
fascinating here here is a Jew who
converts but nevertheless holds on to so
much of his Jewish identity particularly
his relationship to holla hot the Jewish
law we perhaps we'll come back to him a
little later on so my second testimony
then is a rebuke of macaw by his former
disciple Stanislaw hoga one more a
snapshot and this has recently come to
me one of the great joys of this project
was spending a month in Oxford working
in believe it or not an entire archive
of a lung society it's all there I mean
these missionaries you know that maybe
they had only one or two Jews that were
converting but they had 10 boxes of
material on those two Jews I mean they
were they documented themselves they
took themselves quite seriously and it
is really unbelievable the amount of
material that is there so in a
manuscript Oxford
an Oxford manuscript in a letter penned
by McCall from Poland to the Reverend CJ
Hawtrey in London 1826 this was during
the period when McCall was stationed in
Warsaw he discusses the details of
appearing a translation of the Old
Testament for the lun society and
relating how he had paid a Jew to read
and correct their translation until the
Jews wife complained and was forced to
cease his work she obviously didn't like
her husband doing the work alone society
he mentions parenthetically how he
arrived in Berlin to purchase some
prized Hebrew books and then all of a
sudden he's no longer talking about his
missionary activity but rather he is
talking about Jewish books and how he
loves them and how he has found a
remarkable sale he mentions he got a
Kabbalah denude oughtta this remarkable
work of Christian Hebraic ISM this
anthology of Kabbalistic texts of in in
Latin and he purchased it for a song and
then he talks about he also was able to
acquire the chef at you who da of eben
verga and Isaac trocas kaizuka mona
which is an unbelievable anti-christian
work which he claims he needs to write a
response to he prides himself on
purchasing these books for the loan
society library in Warsaw for an
excellent price he is excited that books
are a part of his cultural world and he
wants to share this with his Christian
colleague in London so in the end who is
the real McCall this is a little
elaborate introduction I know but I
think each little snapshot gives you a
taste of it was he a unique Christian
with a genuine love for Jews and Judaism
or was he a deceiver an imposter who
denigrated the rabbi's unfairly or was
he a sincere he Bray us through greatly
valued the learning of the Jews for its
own sake and I guess my answer is
perhaps perhaps he was simultaneously
all three so that is where I am going
now the basic outline in McCall's
distinguished career is easily
constructed from
the standard history of London society
of a man named kidney from a numerous
references of McCullough in the annual
minutes of the society extinct in the
archives of the bounty and library that
I mentioned in the journal called Jewish
intelligence which is a remarkable a
testimony to the activities of these
missionaries and their awareness of Jews
and particularly from the warm
reminiscences of his daughter mrs.
Elizabeth thin the one in the corner
which I'm coming too right away amochol
also wrote many books at least 50 books
and I'll show you them in a second
sermons and other addresses and from
references to him on the part of many
contemporaries particularly those
associated with the society during his
lifetime including the eulogies one of
them I've already mentioned in other
words he was a figure of an enormous
stature within this missionary world
holding very important clerical and
educational offices and eventually a
distinguished professorship at King's
College I tried I told my colleague I
believe it and I went online at King's
College and there is such a thing called
the Alexander McCall scholarship in the
Religious Studies department and I have
a colleague andreea shots who teaches
there and I wrote to her and I said
could I apply for that scholarship I
thought it would really be appropriate
and I course I could not but I'm I well
I hope to give a lecture on mccoll I
think it's really cool he was a
professor of Bible in Judaic Studies at
King's College for many years let me
give you in a paragraph I'm going to
stop reading this in a second I have it
in front of me and I don't like to read
but I'm as you see I'm doing it kind of
and then I want to sort of move on and
show you some slides McCoy was born at
dublin in May on May sixteenth 1799 and
he died at London in 1863 educated at
Trinity College Dublin he was sent as a
missionary to Poland in 1821 where he
studied Hebrew edition rubik he
continued to live in Warsaw for nearly
10 years interesting the Grand Duke
Constantine the Crown Prince of Prussia
and Sir Henry rose in his work what is
really interesting and I think this has
been pointed out by others the political
function of these missionaries and their
relationship with a Russian government
and how they have won them over and
clearly how Haskell ah or in Jewish
enlightenment in Eastern Europe becomes
intertwined with missionary activity and
how insensitive or unaware let's put it
that way the Orthodox Jewish community
is of this entanglement while those who
need to do to separate the two are the
musky leave in other words giving you or
a picture of whatever what I'm going to
come to the musky leme are the ones that
are end up defending rabbinic tradition
not the Orthodox who couldn't who are
oblivious and that is a certain irony in
itself as well but we will come back to
that in 1837 he produced initially as
installments his elaborate attack upon
the town would called the old paths over
a whole year every week another
installment was published it was
published and then finally this evoked
considerable interest on the part of the
Jews and was translated into several
languages including Hebrew nativo olam
of courses the Hebrew edition by
Stanislav ugh as we mentioned who
apparently claim to perform more than a
mere translation as we've already seen
McCoy wrote vigorously against the
Damascus blood libel here he shows his
love and affection for the Jews and I
will show you that in a second
demonstrating his profound respect for
the high moral standard of Jews he also
as we said became a professor of Hebrew
and wrote many works on on Jewish
subjects now what I want to do is to
give you a little taste of this first of
all let's so so this is his family
Michelle go on to the next one let me
see what I got here I have more children
sorry I didn't get
Emily and Louis I'm sorry about that but
now all right now we come to mrs. Finn
so mrs. Finn was married to James Finn
and he became the chief missionary
villain society in Jerusalem so there is
a whole Jerusalem story to this a
professor named Perry at the University
of Haifa has written a whole book on
aspects of this missionary role mrs.
Finn wrote a wonderful a diary in which
he talks at quite a great length about
her father so I just want to give you a
taste of this I don't think I have the
time to read too much but I just want to
give you a little bit of a taste my
father took very great pains to become
thoroughly acquainted with the Jewish
character and mode of life he found that
among them learning was everything and
wealth nothing it was thought an honored
to be the wife of a learned man i
remember well the Yiddish phrase I so
often heard in my childhood now she
claims that McCall spoke to her only in
Hebrew and Yiddish and they wrote to
each other in Hebrew and Yiddish again
this is missionaries so I again say to
yourself you know so these are good
Christians right there is a dividing
line McCreery Christianity and Judaism
but my claim and arguing for mingle
identities it's not so clear it's never
so clear because life is not so clear
she I remember well the Yiddish phrase I
so often heard my childhood and is there
a gallant Amon as the highest praise in
Poland mccall met with 15 boy she tells
us who were acquainted with tom with
literature my father met with a lad who
could put a pin through the leaves of a
Penta to din site the words my father
was familiar with the law of Moses and
the cursive writing of Hebrew which is
different from the square characters
that we see in printed books or in the
roles of the law he run up the whole of
the five books eight times with his own
hand he also taught me the cursive
writing and I continually get letters
written to him here it is the language
being either pure Hebrew or Yiddish he
goes she goes on to describe principal
Jewish towns among them better chef
where the greatest number of Jews lived
traveling was difficulty slept in barns
he ate with the horses
he ate potatoes and honey on Shabbat and
a Jewish in he received Jewish visitors
in in Warsaw knows the stories about his
intimate relationship with Jews he's
just as fascinating as a scholarship as
you will see and then of course she
speaks about the first convert a Jewish
lady which the Grand Duke wanted
baptized in the palace but his major
prize was next slide Barbara Miyako
schwarzenberg now and here's an
opportunity he introduced my second miss
you man this house is Margo leo maybe
some of you who work on 19th century
have heard of before because margali
Oates was again another Eastern European
Jew who came to England and there he was
baptized as a Protestant and then he
began writing books on Jewish history he
is the quintessential historian of Anglo
jewelry in the 19th century wrote a
three volume work but he wrote actually
more than that he wrote several other
works on on Anglo Jewish history in
which he saw it as his own history he
also wrote on the Bible he was
interested in poetics he was fascinated
by Sephardic Jewish literature as many
19th century Ashkenazi Jews were and he
spent his whole career writing about
Jewish literature for him he was a good
Christian in every form or shape but
nevertheless culturally ethnically he
saw himself as a Jew and therefore again
we have this this very interesting
connection between Judaism on the part
of someone who has given up his his
religion but nevertheless sees himself
as the one that needs to tell the story
of Anglo jewelry now in his account this
is about fortson book he lived from
upwards of 20 years and so on and then
I'm talks about his deathbed recants his
first
profession of faith and repeating the
words hear o Israel the Lord our God the
Lord is long the look of the Lord is one
God the Jews works over there for army
that we did when the vital spark
inevitable Israel I've indeed was about
to quit the mortal frame beautiful a
19th century English they crowded design
saints chamber what were his last words
on earth to be rather you wish to know
what they said dime every drop of blood
and they were goggle and that would see
each such drop of cry lab that I am
dying full of joy peace believing the
relation Israel or Jesus what is
interesting about this character is that
he insisted on dressing as he was in
other words he refused to take off his
beard and he wore his yarmulke and he
had his tits asst and nevertheless this
was a the convert Rabbi Abraham Jacob
schwarzenberg going on very quickly i'm
not going to i don't want to read too
much more but she she goes on to
describe then we're back to Elizabeth
Finn father began writing a series of
papers to show how rabbis had departed
to the Mosaic law and this of course
became the old paths he using the motto
of the words of the Prophet Jeremiah
exerting his people to look back to the
old paths the papers took the form of a
double page in English with Hebrew
quotations from the tumble in the Bible
they were widely distributed and excited
much attention for about a year one
result she claims again and this comes
up or a second time was the founding of
what she called Reform Judaism a Jewish
gentleman was sent to my father to
verify his Hebrew quotations from the
books in the library it was in that way
that mr. marks congregation was began
Reverend marks was the first rabbi of
the Reform congregation in London that
is a claim which he makes interesting
enough hoga makes fun of the claim and
says it's ridiculous he he had no impact
whatsoever or very minimal impact on the
Reform Jews but be that as it may she
sees it one a little bit more detail and
I finish with her but first of all the
next slide so here are some of the
Gold Pass 1830 786 2012 and i'm going to
show you in a second a amazon where
we're going to see every one of these
books i mean i can't keep my books in
print but Alexander McCall's books are
all in print and they're all on the
internet I mean you obviously somebody's
still reading them ah so here's the
german edition here's the hebrew nativo
toll um ok so the ear happy rwanda and
so on okay father gave her hebrew
lessons she slept one night in her
father's study and there i found on the
bookshelves volumes of Schlegel
Shakespeare in German interesting that a
london missionary is reading Shakespeare
in German and this has been explained to
me that indeed there was something more
elegant about the German translation
than the original at least in the
perspective of of nineteen seventy
Europeans in the early morning I read
Romeo and Juliet amid Midnight's a
midsummer night's dream and others in
German this was my first acquaintance
with Shakespeare so I has nothing to do
with anything but I just thought it was
really cool um ok now let me show you
the other words so here is his
translation of Prayer so you see you can
Dhavan in there the Christian missionary
set up in a place which they call
Palestine place in London they would
have friday night services and this
would be their prayer book go on and
here is a remarkable sketches of Judaism
and Jews and there are several editions
that again look 2012 with pretty
pictures and so on this is his essay you
will hear about reform judaism is in
there i'm going to talk about women in a
second that is in there as well his
description of his visits among the
hussy demon eastern europe are in there
and believe it or not they are loving
portraits i mean as you will see the
love and that first text that i gave you
does come through in especially in this
book and go a little farther we'll see
what else we got here
I want to speak very briefly about this
look later on but as an early modernist
Isaac Roberto Castro of course puts us
in seventeenth-century Amsterdam this is
a work in response to the english
translation of a converso who wrote an
anti-christian work isaac aerobie the
castro and believe it or not to show you
how much Jewish history intermingles the
translator was none other than grace
Aguilar I hope you know she is she's a
very famous a woman novelist of Jewish
books of the 19th century that have been
studied by several scholars in England
and she was out there translating a
Sephardic work and of course Nicole
noticed it and wrote a two volume
response so we have the 17th century now
invading of the 19th century and I think
that's all for now except let's go on to
the next one we see where I am okay oh
yeah so i want to show you can buy these
all i'm not an agent from a call but
look they're all every one of these you
can okay keep going alright so now we
come to this so here is a very
interesting part of our story well
dhakad by Jonathan Frankel as well in
the midst of this extraordinary crisis
where Jews are accused again of the
blood libel in Damascus and newspapers
are covering this all over Europe mccall
stands up to write his own work charging
that these accusations are totally false
I'm not going to read this with you I
mean you can see this from the title
keep going now 1840 there is a repeat no
evidence whatsoever it said it said or
go on and this so what is really
interesting about this is that he
constructs a community of Jewish
Christians a list of competent witnesses
approving of his work here are the
persons neither afraid nor shame to give
their names we're going to stick our
necks out and defend the Jews are and
this baseless charge of using a blood
for two men
mozza go on we then decide by nations
Jews and that notice how this is framed
and having lived in the years of
maturity in the faithful practice of
honoring Judaism but now by the grace of
God members of The Church of Christ if
someone who protests that we have never
directly or indirectly heard of much and
so on go on and here are the names and
their forces Moses Margo Lyon right
there and a hope of other name some of
them I can recognize some of my hands
but very Jewish Ashkenazic names these
are the prizes of on society of
individuals who they succeeded in
converting but all of them you see where
they're born cool and Poland and Hungary
and someone and so forth all of them are
now Christians and now take their stand
and defending their former
co-religionists go on and here are some
more names and and so you see there is
already community which stand behind
McCall and not necessarily large but
nevertheless quite impressive in terms
of names that he's accumulated okay now
what I want to do and I want to mention
in addition to all of these works mccall
translated one of the commentaries of
David Kim please work on the Bible a
translation numerous sermons and
addresses clearly there are other works
in his sermons there is so much Jewish
learning in so many citations from
rabbinic literature but what I want to
do now is rather quickly because I'm
going to run out of time or I didn't
wasn't even aware when I started but I'm
not going to I'm going to do this rather
quickly I want to give you a taste of
some of the arguments before we leave
this and again I have all of these texts
but we're not going to have time to read
them but i just want to show you so
basically the argument of nativo to
allah is very wise in the sense that he
uses to tactics in order to win over the
Jews basically he says he loves the Jews
he cares about their fake deeply the
problem is those damned rabbis who are
messing everything up if only they could
see the truth of their Judaism through a
Christian lens
they would appreciate of course the
grand or of their own religiosity and
they would come forward to confess their
faith in Jesus Christ now of course
that's not a novel argument at all I
mean there are there are hundreds of
years of this kinds of argumentation but
as you will see the praise is really
quite powerful as i'll give you show you
one example the other argument that he
uses is he knows that most christian
exigence have used midrashic texts or
Kabbalistic texts to prove their case
and this is the easy way out you know I
mean rabbi's say everything when they
start telling stories and homilies and
you can find anything you know the
Messiah is at the gate of aroma that
must be Jesus of course etc etc etc so
he says I'm not going to use those texts
rather I'm going to use the shahana rule
or the codes are particularly the
taurine in other words i'm going to use
jewish hahaha or i'm going to use the
prayer book that is the standard liturgy
of Ashkenazi and Sephardic Jews in
London translated by another character
in one of my previous books it's so
wonderful to work on a book and then
discover a character from another book
you know it's as if they're all
connected David Levy who was a very
important translator of Hebrew texts
into English at the end of the 18th
century so he's going to use David
levies prayer book which is the kosher
prayer book if indeed the Jews are dava
ting this stuff then they must believe
it right how can you say it's false or
its its its tangential or its peripheral
to their own experience now let's go so
here here is the nobility of Jewish
culture what's really interesting here
is I'm going to just skip down notice he
talks about the Jewish printing presses
those of you interested in the history
of the book he's aware of them all the
19th century is a great period of the do
printing press send forth a number of
new works every year me whether we look
at the revenge Jews of ancient amount of
times of us admit that they are a people
of no meaning collection power let me
when reflecting the Jewish sister let
him remember that for nearly 1800 years
they have been an outcast wandering
persecuting the press people and he will
find it little short of a miracle next
that the Jews should have any leisure at
all but when they looks at the extent
about literature its variety and the own
minds etc etc you must admit that there
is in the confirmation of the Jewish
mind in a love of learning you know aid
of a nobility and irresistible
elasticity you can read it yourself but
he really likes the Jews I mean is he's
just doing this to to show off I mean
there's something about he was impressed
by the experience that he had living
among Eastern European Jews for nine to
ten years at the same time going to the
next one this is hard to read i'm not
going to go through this all but on the
other hand of course the standard
arguments so here is of course the
intolerance the double morality that
Jews like jews better than they like
non-jews the the Noahide commandments
are not equal to the Jewish and he gives
up many examples and here is one so this
is his commentary on CH Muhammad ha you
know from the Passover Haggadah pour out
your wrath on the heathens and he said
you know it's one thing to talk about
Hayden's as he goes on here but we
beautiful Protestants in England I mean
why would we be why should we be
victimized by that wrath I mean what's
going on here we're a different kind of
Christian notice I'm a very typical
Protestant stance you know the bad guys
are the Catholics popery and the good
guys of course are the Protestants and
therefore he for him this is hypocrisy
go on to the next one alright so now
here are two themes which come out which
do reflect much more than I a 19th
century kind of context I'm not going to
read this but what he spends a great
deal of time on is talking about how
holla ha destroys economically poor Jews
and how we open up our kitchens to them
but those damned rabbis won't allow
them to take our bread because it's not
kosher and therefore they starve in the
streets of London of course there was
there was a lot of poor Jews in the 19th
century in London so indeed he
constantly harps back to the fact that
the people that are impoverished are
those who are the poor who experienced
the tyranny hit the so-called tyranny of
the haha the next one now of course the
other theme is women there's a lot of
missionary texts that deal with women so
this is not so a typical of the 19th
century at all as I discover it looks
like feminism but it is already
something that's been going on for quite
a long time again I don't want to read
through it all but the spirit of
rabidism is it is which degrades women
hood and does not suffer to exercise the
faculties which God was given Robin is
and lays it down is an axiom at the
sudden the law of God is no part of
omens duty and that to teach his donors
the Word of God no part of paternal
obligation women and slaves are exempt
from the city well go on and so he goes
through this whole thing a rabbit isn't
teachers that a woman is unfit to give
legal evidence etc etc and this is all
against standard but nevertheless it
appears in full form and here notice it
ho tum with Tehran coating a from from
the Mishnah Torah go on rabun ISM
excludes women from being counted as
part of the synagogue or high aim and
daily prayers notice the sources that
he's using and so on rabinus and teaches
that to be a woman is as great a
degradation as to be a heathen or slave
and provides the same form of
thanksgiving and so on now that of
course is again standard tropes but what
i want to show you which i think is
quite incredible is the following in
sketches we have a long discussion of a
book that he discovers of tennis these
women's prayers which in recent years
have a why slur has made famous in her
book
telling these thisi praise were either
written for women or later on by women
he discovers a work and he no title-page
he describes I'm he's really a
bibliophile describes exactly what he's
reading a small pamphlet of 16 pages and
the top of the first page the title
appears the three gates it if he not
written by a pious woman Sarah the
daughter of our doctor and Rob more too
high a blessed memory grandson of the
Robin dr. Rob rabbi mordechai who is
president of the beta Midrash and the
Holy congregation of brisk the three
refers to three Commandments hollow
ceremonial uncleanliness and lighting
the lamps adiphene if a new moon the
third for the Holy Days yamim nura m and
the prayer as he argues reveals a deep
conviction of guilt a fearful
expectation of punishment and a firm
persuasion that an atonement in the
merits of another are necessary to
procure forgiveness like the Roman estea
argues the rabbinic Jewess looks to the
merits of the saints and trust in the
efficacy of purgatorial suffering that's
his own Christian take on this prayer
but believe it or not he translates the
entire tokina into English a hundred
years before haba wisely did the same
thing in her book the voices of the
matriarch so if have had only known she
could have already found an English
translation of this text 100 years
earlier by a missionary but again it is
written out of a loving concern and
affection and appreciation for the
Jewish woman he criticizes the rabbi's
but heey Nobles this text and this
Jewish women two more points I want to
make about this and then I want to move
on to the last part of my talk the
reformed Jewish connection I've
mentioned are ready let's go on to the
next page so here is the introduction to
the second edition of the old paths and
there you will see his claims
reform judaism and so on I'm trying to
pick up so evening indeed the Jews are
great and noble people on the majority
of details of the system by which they
have been bad down under certain men for
centuries so in there he is I'm
zealously undertaking a defensive the
whole maintain a trap tribalism is a
perfect model of charity and wisdom
regarding all passes of your elimination
common anti-jewish prejudice such
persons are requested to compare these
papers with the articles in Jewish
periodical apologies really yar wonders
written by dr. Samuel whole time who was
a radical reform rabbi so he says if you
really want to see anti-jewish stuff
read this rabbi it's worse than my book
basically what he's saying his claim
about having influenced the Reform
synagogue in London is complicated but
what is interesting is that in sketches
he refers to three of the sea nodes of
reform jews in the 19th century and he
says look they're doing all the right
thing they're attacking rabbinic Judaism
but damn it they don't go the whole way
why don't they just see the light and
stop playing games and uttering these
precious platitudes about rabbinic
Judaism they are wrong also in other
words it becomes at a certain point
frustrated the Reform Jews are halfway
there but they haven't gone the whole
way so therefore that there is something
wrong with them so the hypocrisy of what
he calls reform catechisms finally 20
next one so this is back to Isaac our OB
de Castro and this is really quite
interesting here so the way he attacks
Isaac arrbida Custer oh go on to the
next page is to history of that very
city that is Amsterdam where Robbie
professor you
afford proof of the assertion when he
fled from say in France he found a
refuge in toleration another country
possessing a Christian faith just as
Jews in England new but they're about
the same time another you here we are in
other words the way to deal with Roberto
Castro is to print present oriole
dacosta where the cost of you recall is
the one that was basically according to
his autobiography beaten up by the mama
by the rabbi's of Amsterdam the 17th
century so about the same time of the
Jew 11 Portugal found the jury is in the
master and refused that liberty of
conscience which the Christianity
abstinent accorded Gabriel want to be
called or oiled acosta came thither like
a Romeo his mother and brother invest
Judaism soon find Eric rabidism was not
the religion of the penta to be the end
to say so and was persecuted by the Jews
of the hatred so intense so that which
anime the inquisitors against the Romeo
in any quotes this whole long text of
oriel dacosta the point being that the
rabbi's are also inquisitors from his
perspective that the rabbi's are like
the Papists that they are Catholics and
Jews are the same they have this
mediated tradition through their
exclusive interpretation and therefore a
true Judaism and a true Christianity can
only come forth within the context of
Protestant Christianity alright so I
think I've said enough i just want to
say one two more things and then i'm
coming i'm moving us towards the next
step so that's my mccall there's so much
more to read by him that it's almost
overwhelming but he is an interesting
figure who as you see is clearly a
person who has a deep affection and
commitment to Jews and Judaism at the
same time of course he can overcome his
hostility and frustration in rabbinic
Judaism which he also knows intimately
when he dies I just want to mention or
in 1860s he ends up to be less than a
happy man for two reasons and this has
come to me recently so I
we'll have to fully develop it his son
in 1866 three years after his death
publishes a work of letters that
appeared in Jewish missionary
publications in which he claims that the
London society in in Jerusalem has
mistreated converts which he personally
supervise it seems that a controversy
broke out between these converts and the
Consul General of the mission in
Jerusalem and they were and the converts
were put in jail and he was incensed
this is not the way if indeed we believe
in Christian love how is it possible to
take converts and treat them so poorly
so he publicly reveals himself as an
opponent of the London society in the
words taking an opposition only a few
years before he dies or almost at the
point where he dies the second
interesting aspect of this story is that
in 1860 a work appears cold is it essays
and I can't find it now I don't have in
front of me a work of essays using
history and archaeology to argue for a
critical reading of the Bible written by
Anglican theologians in other words the
beginning of a biblical criticism in a
very serious way on the part of his own
co-leaders within within the church he
is incensed and here he become so
preoccupied in the last three years of
his life defending the sanctity of a
very literal reading of the Old
Testament that he loses sight of his
Jews and his converts in other words at
this point the world around him seems to
be crumbling instead of making progress
he seems to be losing progress now as
the new reading of the Old Testament and
the New Testament has challenged the
very core of his traditional Christian
faith so that's a very interesting
ending to his story now I just want to
talk about one more thing so I talked
about to miss you midi my one make sure
you get your money's worth tonight so i
talked about one missionary and two
Mishima Dame Margot leo diamond
chinden of course Stanislaw hoga now
finally the musky lean the Jewish
reaction and this is what makes a full
circle here and a complete conversation
that I'm trying to reconstruct what
makes McCall offensive especially what
makes the McCall offensive especially
interesting for the intellectual and
cultural history of 19th century jury is
the remarkable Jewish response it
elicits next slide okay these are some
of them there are more but these are the
most important and I'm going to single
out 3 a 1 is Rashi phien Samuel Joseph
in darchei other na which is a
manuscript he intended to publish it he
dedicated it to Moses month a few of the
great financier but some reason Moses
month if you never gave him the money to
publish it so it appears all ready to be
published at sitting in the heap
university library but it's a text of
about 350 pages against McCall the
second is the remodel Isaac bear
Levinson and there are actually two
works yeah shes lonely and zaruba vel
and these are large works i haven't i've
only worked through about half of them i
still have to read the rest but they are
extraordinary texts are in which these
musky lean these enlightened Jews
sitting in Vilna for example in the case
of leben ssin are forced to respond to
McCall in Hebrew and to argue with his
with his very serious argument and the
last one is Elias is equal setting or
which from Warsaw which is very late
look how many years after 1837 when it
came out were these effective I'm not
sure and all the other one necessarily
interesting is Raphael Kazan he was a
Sephardic rabbi and in the man in in
Syria and he wrote two works against
mccall because apparently the work was
translated into Ladino and therefore he
felt the need to respond and and and he
does now I have not studied all these
works yet and that's why I'm working on
but I'm going through at least the three
important musky lean three of the most
important writers of the Haskell ah I
felt the need to pen significant length
in Hebrew responses we mentioned well 3i
have quickly identified the six
additional responses and there are many
more I'm sorry I said Rafael Kazan is
the rabbi of Aleppo in Baghdad besides
these eight compositions there are
undoubtedly more mccall's clever polemic
would ultimately do less damage to the
welfare of the Jewish community the
insidious Damascus blood libel as we
said on which McCall had published the
sympathetic defense of the Jews yet like
the impact of the Damascus affair the
McCall affair was highly publicized all
over Europe and elicited an intense
transnational response as I've said from
Jewish leaders intellectuals across the
continent most fascinating is the role
of the musky lean in their counter
arguments against McCall they were the
same Jewish critics of traditional
Judaism would challenge rabbinic
Authority and objected to the excessive
preoccupation of yeshiva students with
Talmud study in the first place at the
expense of the acquisition of general
culture and in excoriated the
parochialism and narrow-mindedness of
their co-religionists due to Talmudic
obscurantism and cultural isolation
these same critics of the Talmud now
felt obliged to defend the ladder to
argue for the very humanity and moral
sensitivity which McCall had argued was
lacking in the Talmud in the first place
defending traditional Jewish mores as
embodied in the Talmud while criticizing
its stranglehold on Jewish culture
presented the same intellectuals with a
delicate balancing act in which they
strove to define their own Jewish
identities their own relationship to the
ancient sources their tradition with a
new bold and a strategy to transform
Judaism
core the Jewish counter-attacks against
the English missionary thus represent
thoughtful and nuanced articulations of
what Judaism meant in the context of
their own societies and how it could
still retain its authentic values while
reforming itself in the light of the new
exigencies and challenges of the modern
era these texts are thus important as
contributions to modern Jewish
self-reflection important especially
because they originated among Jewish
thinkers beyond Germany and must offer a
different perspective from those from
those of the better-known german jewish
thinkers i would love to talk about them
at greater length let me just say one or
two words and then I'm going to close
and I forgive me if I spoke too long
already they are all part of the
moderate Haskell ah they are profound
rabbinic scholars in their own right who
read several languages and were
influenced by German culture in other
words the notion that Eastern European
Jews were not connected to the West is
really proved wrong by many sources but
especially by these texts themselves all
three of them that is as Eiffel Levinson
and theme we're all connected with each
other and we have their correspondence
so they were very much in touch with
each other what is interesting about
their knowledge they hold up an ideal of
what I rabbinic scholar is all about and
they try to distance themselves from a
call and arguing that a rabbinic scholar
and particularly as his reboul speaking
needs not only to know rabbinic text but
he needs to know Roman history he needs
to know Latin and Greek yeah they
actually say that too bad your professor
Seth Schwartz is not here tonight
there's to be and other sets wars in
other words the standards of rabbinic
scholarship is to know ancient history
and they spend a great deal of time
speaking about ancient Christian history
in comparing with ancient Jewish history
and thus to show the humanity of the
rabbi's and the lack of humanity of the
Christians who who treated Jews poorly
when they had the chain
so what we have here is a and also a
democratic Judaism for them rabbinic
texts are not the Divine Word of God but
are simply the interpretations of divine
law and therefore a notion of tradition
the most other interesting thing about
this is that they do quote Catholic
authorities against Protestants and so
on but they spent a lot of time talking
about nachman crock Mel about zaharia
Frankel they quote Franco all the time
in other words they seem to appear as if
the conservative judaism or traditional
historical Judaism or the notion of
tradition is set out in dark ke hamishe
nave zaharia Franco seems to have
influenced their own understanding of
Judaism was we tend to see reform and
conservative is a Western phenomenon and
not as an Eastern phenomenon but clearly
they are reading these German Jewish
thinkers and they are opting for a
middle path which looks very close to
zaharia Frankel's version of rabbinic
tradition and rabbinic Judaism I could
say a lot more but I but I won't but
what is really interesting here is that
defenses of the Talmud on the part of
musky lean and the revival of the Jewish
Christian debate in the 19th century
themes which you would think should not
fall into a such a modern here for me
this is you know like very modern I
start you know my first book is on the
15th century so but define these motifs
repeated over and over again in a
different form suggests how interesting
and how enchanting this is and also
suggests that what we need to do of
course is to consider more seriously the
kind of self-reflection that emerges
from these and of course this is going
on now there are many Eastern European
Jewish scholars who have done serious
work continued to serious work on this
period including Michaelson aslam ski of
course but clearly there is more to be
done and there are more texts to be
studied and the links between east and
west and the relationship between and
the place of the Christian polemic or
the Jewish Christian polemic in the
context of the shaping of modern Judaism
these are all themes that come out so
clearly
reading these responses so if I've done
nothing else I hope I've convinced you
that I have a good topic whether I'm mad
enough to complete it I don't know but
nevertheless I have found a new
engagement with mingle identities with
this slippage between Judaism
Christianity and I hope it has
entertained you at the very least in the
last hour so on forgive me for Speaking
so long thank you very much for
listening to me no questions is delayed
I think we'll take a couple um thank you
so much first of all for joining us and
for such an interesting lecture I think
we're all looking forward to the book
now one thing I do want to mention is
that I think it's so appropriate that
this this talk took place here in the
union theological seminary building
whose Burke library holds a trim a huge
missionary collection which was recently
processed actually and is now available
for use but let's let's take a couple of
questions if we if we have any other
ways yeah go ahead
well first of all there is evidence that
he did meet dr. marks the the rabbi of
the Reform congregation of London and
that he did tried to persuade him in his
own understanding of Christianity
Judaism and they had conversations and
there is in fact evidence one of Marxist
sermons he kind of elaborates on on on
themes which I christian missionary
would be happy to find but besides this
particular evidence of a human
connection what he was essentially
seeing was that you know Reform Jews
were critical of course of the rabbinic
hegemony and were arguing that
individuals based on on their own
conscience had the right to choose what
is meaningful what is not meaningful
about about Jewish observance and
particularly in looking at the radical
reformers like hold high man hold on is
really right radical who emphasized only
the aspect of morality and the notion of
a mission of Israel that is here mission
doesn't mean the same thing as asthma
Coleman a mission of Israel being
bringing the social values of Judaism to
the world as a whole as being the
ultimate goal of the Jew in this a
McCall felt very genuinely that there
was a kinship between what he was saying
about his own version of Protestant
morality and and Protestant ethic sand
and this reform Jewish ethic so he
pushed them he said so why don't you
accept my position and he looked very
carefully at their literature and
particularly followed very carefully in
detail the various conventions of reform
rabbis that were going on throughout the
middle of the 19th century and he saw
hypocrisy in other words he said on the
one hand you criticize the rabbis on the
other hand you will not take the leap in
other words by giving it up entirely you
still quote the ethics of the fathers
you still refer to rabbinic homily
you still how you want to have one foot
in and one foot out that makes no sense
to me whatsoever so he became extremely
frustrated in the end and and he
articulates his animus towards them I
could say more but I can't really go on
with this but but clearly it is a very
imposing episode my own argument I it's
irrelevant but I happen to be reform
rabbi as well not a very good one but a
reform rabbi not a very good jus either
but I'm but anyway I don't forget about
that but in any case so I don't like the
idea of McCall being in bed with Reform
Jews at all but I'm simply an historian
here and I'm reporting the way McCall
saw it and and clearly you know Gershom
Scholem argued that the this type of
teens and Reform Jews were also
connected everybody wants to put the
Reform Jews and in with the bad guys or
McCall was not a bad guy in like the
sabot Ian's but in any case it seems to
me that indeed he tried very hard he saw
them as progress in his own mission but
he eventually became very frustrated
when they did not embrace him totally so
that's a quick answer okay
you